what is the age you think depends you
can start doing it and people don't
judge you 22. I try to uh they they were
going to do a campaign with you well no
I pitched me great I wanted to pitch me
they didn't buy it I threw my agent I
said let me be the depends guy you know
and because you you would take that
product through the roof yeah because
number one I don't want to use the
public bathroom like here yeah I'm just
comfortable and I thought I'd be a great
spokesman where I can just go listen the
pens just I never miss anything I am
there for it all wow I'm just a little
right close up as you zoom in yeah it's
a montage of you being super busy you
don't have time to take back that's
right you can't stop it won't stop that
starts trending and then we'll all just
pee in our pants